I said of finals welcome back to another
movie clips review i'm jay s and i'm
alex and today we're taking a swing at
million dollar arm but I normally don't
like baseball movies but I would argue
million dollar arm is not a baseball
movie what would you argue it is I would
say it's a human interest story
interesting first and foremost but we
don't actually watch any baseball games
during the movie on thurs might be one
in a mom yeah there's one of the montage
very brief okay but the rest and let's
just say Jon Hamm plays JB he's a sports
agent mm-hmm and he's trying to come up
with the next million-dollar idea so to
speak and he comes up with the brilliant
concept of going to India finding
cricket players and bringing them back
to LA and training them into NLB
potential a lot of times really good
baseball movies in many ways don't focus
on the game itself because the game in
my opinion is a allegory of other things
okay and like for instance Ken Burns the
documentarian guy he loves baseball and
and one thing he said I thought
interesting is that baseball is one of
the few sports that goes throughout most
of American modern history because it
existed in such and since the 1850s
interest so yeah Jon Hamm I think should
be a leading man every summer yeah
because yeah I mean he's movie star
potentially he's got the classic
old-school looks yeah he's a
legitimately fine talent if you've seen
like his amazing career and track record
on madman so far yeah and i think i'll
have time now that madman is over yeah
but lake bell brings something a little
special too yeah she she provides an
atypical acting kind of presence from a
pretty typical kind of role mm-hmm we're
like I've always liked her her she's
really she's a beautiful looking actress
but she's also really awkward as a just
her personality yeah how's across is
that so yeah I'm
a great cast all around like we've said
on my main problem with million dollar
arm probably was that it's by the
numbers you know exactly where this was
going it's a film that if you go in
expecting it to be which it is a Disney
family drama about sports it basically
fulfills all the requirements yeah but I
will say I love what they did towards
the end where JB had the opportunity to
give this sort of like final rousing
speech and he hands it off yeah and that
was a really nice touch um and most
emotional scene of the movie for me
there's some moving stuff back in India
like when they're leaving their family
over the very first time mm-hmm and so
yeah I am a fan of this movie which is
something I never thought I'd say all
right folks that's our review of million
dollar arm it's currently playing in
cities all across the country and a
recommendation from both of us mm-hmm so
for movie clips I'm j/s
thanks for watching